Hi. Welcome back.
In the last session, we started our
discussion of growth investing by
looking at small cap stocks. In this
one, I'm going to focus on another
strand of growth investing where you
focus on companies that are just going
public. Private businesses going public.
The initial public offering story. The
question we're going to try to answer
is, is there an opportunity here for
investors at the time a company goes
public for them to make money?
Now, the process by which private
businesses go public follows a fairly
established structure.
The private business approaches an
investment bank.
Usually because you need the investment
banking advice and support along the
way. And we'll talk about what's
changing about that process. That
investment bank puts together a
syndicate of other banks.
That bank then provides an investment
banking guarantee, a price guarantee.
And don't get too excited. It's not as
ironclad as it looks in return for an
underwriting fee.
What's the underwriting fee? A
percentage of the proceeds from the IPO
offering go to the investment bank.
And to make an investment in an initial
public offering in the US, a company has
to file a prospectus. A prospectus has
all of the financial statements you get
in a traditional public company.
And at least in theory, everything
should be restated using accounting
standards that govern public companies.
So, if you look at the process, here's
how it begins. The company approaches an
investment bank. The investment bank
decides to go ahead and be the lead
investment banker.
The lead investment banker puts together
a syndicate. And the size of the
syndicate will depend on the size of the
offering.
The A prospectus gets filed. And then
investment banker can help the company
put the prospectus. The prospectus
doesn't just give the historical data on
the company.
It lays out what the company hopes to do
with the offering proceeds. The lead
investment bank of values, and I put it
in in quotes because they really price
the company, and they don't that price
is not the final price. They test the
price out, they do a sales pitch, and
eventually they set an offering price
that's guaranteed.
And then the offering happens. At the
offering price, clients of the
investment bank try to get shares at
that offering price, and on the offering
day, the company's open for trading.
That process is coming under now because
there are alternative ways. In fact,
there are some companies
which directly list the market. They
bypass the offering process and an
offering price. They go to the market
and demand and supply an auction process
at the price. There's also a variant
where you set up a special purpose
entity, a SPAC. The SPAC actually is
just collects the cash. You invest in
the SPAC, it's a publicly traded SPAC
with with assets just being the cash
they hold. That SPAC then merges with a
private business, and that is the
process in which it goes public. That
private business is now a public
company.
Direct listings and SPACs are still the
exception. The rule is still this
process, and the question is is there
anything about this process where there
are frictions you can exploit as an
investor?
Well, on the offering day, remember the
investment bank set an offering price,
they guarantee the offering price. One
reason they're able to guarantee the
offering price and not face too much
risk is they sit they systematically
underprice offerings. This is no secret.
It's in the investment banking guidebook
for pricing IPOs. Is you price the IPO
and you knock off 10 or 15% off the
price, you underprice the IPO. We'll
talk about why the issuing company might
be okay with this because this seems
like a leaving money on the table. But
that is the offering price.
The the company opens for trading on the
on the offering day. Given that the
offering price is set too low, no
surprise there's a jump in the price.
And you can see that that jump in the
price in the first day can be a pretty
significant number. In this graph, I
look at the jump in prices and this is
this is a study that goes from 1983 to
2018.
The jump in the price and in each period
that's a less there are a few companies
where their stock price actually drops,
but they're relatively few.
Most companies, the price jumps by 10%,
15%, sometimes by 50, 80, 100%.
There's underpricing systematically on
the off
on the first trading day the price
jumps. Now as an investor you're saying,
I can make money on it. Hold on for a
moment. We'll talk about why it might be
difficult to make money, but on that
first day, clearly there's a jump in the
price.
Now if you track through and look at and
take a deeper look at at the IPO
pricing, on average IPOs are underpriced
by about 15 to 20%. The 15.8% is false
precision, but about 15 to 20%.
And in many cases, the offering price is
in fact revised upwards before the
offering is made because as I said, the
initial price is just a trial price. You
test it out against investors. If they
seem enthusiastic, you might push up the
price. And if you base IPOs based on
whether the offering price was revised
down or revised up before the offering,
you find that the IPOs where the
offering price was revised up see a much
bigger jump in the stock price in the
opening day than the stock than the IPOs
where it was revised down. Again, file
it away if you're an investor saying
maybe I can use that to make money.
And if you look at the IPO underpricing
over time, there you know, IPOs have
always been underpriced, but they ebb
and flow. In this graph, I look at the
underpricing by looking at the return on
the first day. Now when I say return on
the first day to an IPO, we'll talk a
little bit about when that return
happens, but you can look in every
single year, the
at least on average IPOs go up. But, in
some years, the jump in the price is
very small. It's 3%, 5%, some years it's
50%,
80%, and to give you a clue as to when
these big jumps happen,
take a look at the late '90s.
Or
the first part of this decade, 2020,
2021, you could see a big jump. Those
coincided with boom markets, the dot-com
boom, the boom coming out of COVID.
So, clearly there is a correlation here
between how well the market is doing and
what happens on that offering day. But,
there's been underpricing over time.
And that underpricing is not restricted
just to the US. You see it in almost
every European country. This is from a
fairly dated study, but in every single
country, you see on that first day of
trading, the jump in the price.
Now, let's talk about
why as an investor this is not an easy
way for you to make money. Let me play
through a very simplistic strategy. IPOs
on average jump on the first day of
trading, right? What if you subscribe to
100 shares in every single IPO, or 1,000
shares, or a million shares in every
single IPO that's coming?
Right?
And you got those shares at the offering
price, you should see a pretty
significant return because on that first
day the price jumps. You think, "Why
can't I do that?"
Well, three reasons. One is selection
bias. Let's play the play this through.
If you seek out 1,000 shares in every
single IPO that's coming out. Remember,
you're doing this before the offering,
before the offering day.
In some of those IPOs, you're you're to
get the 1,000 shares you asked for.
In some you might get 800, some you
might get 600, some you might get 200.
You're saying, "So what?" Think of the
kinds of companies IPOs where you're
going to get all of the shares you asked
for.
They're going to be the overpriced IPOs,
right? That 10 or 15% of IPOs where the
price goes down
because there the demand for the IPO is
not as heavy.
The IPOs where you will get 200 shares
when you ask for a thousand will be the
most over price will be the most under
priced IPOs the price. So when you look
at your overall portfolio it's going to
be over weighted with IPOs that are over
priced and under weighted with the IPOs
that are most under priced.
So that's the first problem is the
selection bias.
The second is and we'll look take a
deeper look at this as IPO markets go
through hot and cold phases. What does
that mean? There are years where you can
get hundreds of IPOs and years where you
get almost none. And if your entire
strategy is built around IPOs, what do
you do during the famine years? There's
nothing to invest in. And third as we
will see, timing is everything. Even if
you got lucky, you were able to get IPO
shares at the offering price and you got
that first day jump. If you don't sell
at the right time, you might not be able
to harvest the gains that you thought
you were going to have.
So let's dig a little deeper into each
of these problems. Let's start with the
selection bias. Part of it I've already
put on the table which is if you apply
for every IPO, if your IPO is over
priced you'll get all of the shares you
asked for. If your IPO is under priced
you'll get only a fraction of your
request, right? And the small and the
more under priced
the the smaller the fraction will be.
If on top of that investment banks play
favorites and let me explain what I mean
by play favorites.
Investment banks have preferred clients,
have big clients and they might take
their best IPOs, their most
under priced IPOs and give preferred
clients a larger share of those shares.
In which case, if you're an outsider,
you're going to get even fewer shares.
It makes the selection bias worse. Put
simply, if you just try to invest in
every single IPO that's coming out,
you're going to be overweighted. Your
portfolio is going to be overweighted in
overpriced IPOs and underweighted in
underpriced IPOs. In fact, there are
mutual funds and people have tried to
replicate the IPO underpricing in their
portfolios and it doesn't seem to pay
off. That's a selection bias.
The IPO cycle, as I noted, you know, the
number of IPOs change on a year-to-year
basis. And then the amount that they
they try to raise also varies. If you
take a year like 2021, huge year for
IPOs in terms of the amount of money
raised and the number of IPOs. Again,
the late '90s, huge years for IPOs. And
as I mentioned earlier, that might have
something to do with how well the market
is doing. But if your entire investment
philosophy is built around IPOs, what do
you do in the lean years?
How do you get through them? So, that's
the second problem.
And here's the third one.
Let's say you do you get lucky and as I
said, you got you get the IPO, you get
the money on on that first day, 10%, 15%
jump. That's pretty good, right?
Well, if you continue to hold that
stock, and sometimes you might have no
choice. Investment banks might require
you to hold the stock because if you
don't, you're not going to get your next
IPO request.
And the longer you hold the shares, the
more you suffer. In this study, for
instance,
you know, the study looked at the
returns to IPOs after
the IPO in year one, year two, year
three, year four, year five, and every
single year,
the IPO portfolio actually
underperformed the non-issue portfolio.
So, if you made money on the opening day
and you held for 5 years, but end of the
fifth year, you might end up losing
money to somebody who never got in the
IPO and bought non-issuing companies,
traditional public companies, instead.
Now, as a and as an aside, you might
say, "Why do the issuing companies go
along with this? Why do they let
investment bankers underprice their
offerings?"
It's worth remembering that on the
offering day, only a portion of the
shares are offered to the public.
8%, 10%. And that portion has dropped
off over time. You know, 40 years ago in
an IPO, you might have raised 40% of
your shares might have been offered to
the public. Today, it's 8, 6, 5%.
And when you're offering that smaller
percentage, you might be okay with the
underpricing because you would as like a
loss leader in retailing, as something
that will draw on investors to try to
come in to buy your stock because you as
the founder or the VC might not be able
to get rid of your shares for 6 months
or a year, and you want good PR, good
news stories about you, and this is what
it might provide.
Now, if you look at um that study of
what happens post-IPO and you look
across time, you see the phenomenon kick
up over time, which is
every single time period here, if you
look at the day one return, you get the
big upside, but you look at the
three-year return, not so great.
An IPO strategy, almost by definition,
might be a short-term investing
strategy. You get the IPO luckily at the
offering price. You hold through the
first day, and you better get rid of
those shares
pretty quickly, 3 months, 6 months.
And the question is whether you'll be
able to get away with that strategy if
you're an investor who invests only in
IPOs. Will the investment banks even
accept your subscriptions if they know
you're the kind of person who flips the
shares around?
Now, one of the things that you want to
keep in mind, in addition to the fact
that the IPO process itself is getting
disrupted by direct listings and SPACs,
is the type of companies going public
has changed especially in the US.
If you look at the typical company going
public in the 1980s, an Apple or a
Microsoft, these were companies with
well-formed business models, relatively
small revenues, but making money.
Over time, two things have happened. One
is
companies are waiting longer to go
public in terms of size. They're scaling
up more. The median sales of a company
going public has risen over time.
Why they able to get away with it?
Because now you're able to raise capital
not just from venture capital, but from
public equity investors have entered the
private company space. Uber was able to
raise money from Fidelity and T. Rowe
Price well before it went public. So,
the typical company going public is
bigger. And here's the catch.
It's bigger, but it has a less formed
business model. It's more likely to be
money losing. You're getting bigger
money losing companies going public,
especially in the tech and the biotech
space.
And as an investor, investing in these
companies as they go public, you have to
recognize that that brings with it its
own set of risks. Bigger companies,
unformed business models,
you're running the risk that these
business models might never get formed.
So, let's say you after all of this you
decide that you want to make money on
IPOs, and that's going to be the basis
at least of a portion of your investment
philosophy. Might Might not be a core
philosophy.
Here's the key to being a successful IPO
investor. First,
you got to find the right IPOs. Not all
IPOs are equal. As you saw, some IPOs
jump a lot on the on the offering day
and do well in the subsequent period.
Some jump on the offering day, but do
badly in the subsequent period, and some
actually drop on the offering day.
You need to do your research, not take
it for granted that every IPO is going
to give you that 15% jump on the
offering day and deliver returns
thereafter.
And that requires bringing in the tools
of evaluation, tools of investing,
understanding the business of the IPO
before you jump in.
Second, you got to learn to play the
allotment game better. Because remember,
you if you just send out a request for
1,000 shares in every IPO, you get that
selection bias working against you.
If you can tilt the game in your favor
by becoming a preferred client or
working a way to get a larger percentage
of the shares in the enterprise
offerings, it will improve your odds.
And third, you got to figure out how
long you can hold an IPO before you sell
it. Remember, we talked about momentum
trading and in in the context of
trading,
that might need to come into play. You
might want to invest in IPOs and be a
momentum trader and know when to get out
as the momentum is shifting. And if you
can do all of that, it is conceivable
that adding an IPO component to your
philosophy,
so that might be a sub-philosophy, might
actually augment your returns.
I hope you found this session useful,
and I thank you very much for listening.